This personal watercraft leaps, dives, and
barrel rolls with the waves, but it doesn't
capsize. It's been engineered to return to
an upright position in the water, and when it
comes to the fun factor, this diving
watercraft leaves other recreational boats in
its wake. To make the diving Watercrafts
passenger cabin, a worker sprays a gel coat
onto a form and covers it with fiberglass.
A computer driven router then carves into
marine grade plywood to produce structural
backing for the sides of the cockpit.
A worker slathers adhesive putty onto the
plywood part and applies more adhesive to the
fiberglass cockpit.
He presses the plywood to the glued areas of
the cockpit and brushes resin onto the front
of the plywood. After cutting the cockpit
section in two, the crew glues the parts to
the inside of the fuselage.
The fabricating team applies adhesive putty
to the cone shaped bumper known as the
sacrificial nose.
They slide it onto the front of the fuselage
and then screw the bumper in place
temporarily while the adhesive sets.
Another worker stands all the fiberglass
parts of the watercraft to remove bumps and
blemishes. This piece is the engine hatch.
The team bolts the aluminum scaffold to the
floor of the fuselage.
This is a test fit to confirm that the
dimensions are exactly right.
As they install the scaffold, they use dummy
wing shafts to correctly position it within
the vessel. They confirm that the dimensions
are right, and that the scaffold sits plumb
to the base of the watercraft.
The next team inserts the hatch frame in the
rim around the cockpit.
They'll bond the frame in place later with a
liquid plastic and adhesive putty.
After priming the sanded surface of the
watercraft, team members lowered the 300
horsepower engine into the hatch.
This is a dry fit to confirm everything
lines up correctly.
They'll eventually remove the engine for the
final paint and artwork.
As the dry fit continues, they connect the
air tubes to the snorkel fins that deliver
air to the engine.
The ancient hatch has by now also been
primed, and they fit it to the diving
watercrafts main body.
The crew verifies that the hatch sits flush
with the rest of the fuselage.
A worker installs the exhaust outlet into
the hull at the rear of the watercraft.
Crew members slide elevator fins into
bushings at the back.
These fins will control the pitch axis of
the watercraft.
Next they install the jet propulsion system.
Back to the cockpit.
The crew bolts the control pedals to the
floor and run cables to the jet propulsion
unit. The elevator fins and the steering
system.
They reinstall the defense scaffold, which
has been powder coated in a yellow color.
The crew connects the defense to the
scaffold.
They situate the control panel just above
the control pedals.
They run a metal linkage from the dive fins
to a control stick.
They then test the control stick and confirm
it moves the dive planes easily and
correctly. Bucket seats made of lightweight
carbon fiber minimize the load for added
speed. They took a rubber gasket into the
framework for the clear canopy that will
surround the occupants.
They add a bead of sealant where the gasket
mates to the window frame.
The vessel canopy is made of thick, aircraft
grade acrylic.
It's been tinted to repel the sun's rays and
keep the temperature cooler in the cockpit.
The bat canopy serves as a hatch for
accessing the cockpit.
Finally, an artist does a custom paint job
and makes the fuselage look fierce.
With the mechanical components reinstalled,
this diving watercraft is ready to hit the
water. Fasten your seatbelt.
It should be quite a ride.
A diesel exhaust fluid, or Def tank heater
is a device which prevents diesel exhaust
fluid from freezing.
Diesel exhaust fluid is a solution sprayed
into the exhaust system of a vehicle with a
diesel engine to break down dangerous,
polluting chemicals the tailpipe would
otherwise emit.
A worker programs a robotic bender to bend
the cut tube to the required shape.
These bends are so complex that no
traditional manually operated bending machine
would be able to do them this accurately.
The heater sits right inside the holding
tank.
That's why manufacturers use stainless steel
rather than ordinary steel for this tubing.
Stainless steel better resist the corrosive
ness of the fluid.
At the next station, a worker inserts the
bent tube into the tank heater sensor unit.
The tube fits through openings in the sensor
unit's header.
When connected by a cable to the vehicle's
computer, the sensor unit detects the level,
temperature, and quality of the Def.
Next, the worker puts the tubing in a punch
press, which shapes the ends.
He puts those shaped ends in a bender which
curves them.
Another tube made the same way siphons from
the holding tank to a device that sprays the
fluid on the exhaust stream.
He installs a rubber O ring onto this siphon
tube and applies lubricant.
He installs the tube into the header, and
the O ring fits into a notch.
The worker then installs a bracket at the
base of the heater, riveting it to the
tubing. The bracket holds a rubber grommet
that secures the heater in place
inside the tank.
Further up, he rivets on a second bracket to
stabilize the sensor tube that runs down the
center of the sensor unit.
This prevents the tube from rattling.
Then he installs the return tube, which
feeds any excess unsprayed def back to the
holding tank. Retaining brackets apply
pressure to all the O rings, sealing the tube
connections against leaks.
He flips the heater over to attach the drain
tube, which is the bottom half of the return
tube. He caps all the tubes to keep them
clean until
the heater is installed in the vehicle.
He attaches a nylon filter to the siphon
tube, securing it in place with the retaining
clip. As the siphon tube draws the Def from
the holding tank toward the sprayer, the
filter removes contaminants such as sand.
Finally, this rubber grommet snaps into the
bracket at the base of the heater.
The grommet fits over a raised bump on the
tank floor, holding the unit securely in
place. Once connected to the vehicle's
computer, the heater keeps the diesel exhaust
fluid from freezing, no matter how cold the
weather.
Looking to get high on a new water sport
while you literally can riding a flying water
bike. It attaches with a long hose to the
back of a jet ski, elevating you up to almost
40ft above the water where you can perform
aerial flips and spins.
The Jet Skis water thrust feeds three jet
nozzles on the flying water bike.
One propels the bike upward, the other two
feed jet control nozzles that maneuver the
bike. After masking the ends of the
splitter, a worker sprays the completed
frame, jet control nozzles, and other
aluminum parts with powder coat.
This helps protect against corrosion.
The parts go into an oven for up to a half
hour to bake.
The powder coat to a shiny finish.
Then workers install an aluminum cam lock to
securely fasten the fire hose to the
coupling. Another worker attaches the
remaining components to the frame.
First, he screws in the pair of foot plates
on which the rider stands.
Then he bolts the bottom half of each plate
to the parallel support bars, and the top
half to just ahead of the cam lock.
He mounts a padded knee rest to the support
bars.
It can be easily repositioned to accommodate
the rider's height.
On each unpainted end of the splitter, he
installs an internal support ring, then a
precision fit nylon bushing and an external
support ring, which he screws to the
splitter. The worker slides the jet control
nozzle housing over the
bushing and screws it to the internal
support ring.
The two control nozzles maneuver the water
bike to ascend.
You pull back gradually on both of them
simultaneously to descend.
You push forward on both to spin.
You move one forward and one back.
And to do a backflip.
You yank both control nozzles all the way
back.
He assembles the water bike's body.
It's made of molded polyethylene with a
waterproof urethane pad to cushion the front
of the rider's body.
The seat is made of the same padded
material.
Both pad and seat attach with plastic clips.
The hollow body is completely watertight,
which is why the bike floats.
The final step is to mate the body to the
frame.
The completed water bicycle weighs £30.
Once connected to a jet ski with a fire
hose, this water bike flies at a speed of up
to 20mph.
By maneuvering the jet nozzles, it does
backflips, multiple spins, and even dives
20ft under water.
Solar streetlights take energy from the sun
during the day, store it, and then use it to
shine brightly at night.
So even when the sun sets, they still
provide light.
Manufacturing begins with the assembly of an
LED circuit board.
The technician places the optics or lenses
onto the aluminum board and adds a silicone
foam gasket for waterproofing.
She secures the assembly with the stainless
steel plate.
This completes the solar streetlights.
Led board.
The next worker assembles the LED board to
the base of an aluminum heat sink.
It will disperse excess heat from the LED
board.
He uses several screws to secure the LED
board to the heat sink.
He installs the driver, which will provide
power to the LED board.
Once in place, he connects the LED driver to
the input power lead.
While she now builds the decorative housing.
He screws aluminum tiers together.
He applies adhesive to the upper inner rim.
He inserts an optically clear polycarbonate
lens and the flange adheres to the adhesive
coated rim. He screws the LED heatsink
assembly to an aluminum lid.
He now applies a special adhesive to the
outside rim of the light fixture housing.
He presses foam tubing onto the area.
Once compressed by the lid, it will provide
a watertight seal with everything in an
upside down position.
He lowers the assembly over the LED heatsink
and screws it to the lid.
A technician plugs the fixture into an
electrical testing unit.
He confirms that all the LEDs are
illuminating and that there are no electrical
issues. The manufacturers then transfer the
light fixture to a solar light factory.
Upon arrival here, a technician does more
testing to verify that its function hasn't
been compromised along the way.
The team is now ready to add the solar power
system to the LED streetlight.
A technician programs the solar charge and
load controller.
Another team member places the battery that
will hold the solar charge into a vented
cabinet. He connects the battery to a side
clip and ground wire.
He tucks insulating foam into the sides and
connects the load fuse to the battery wiring.
He plugs the controller into the battery.
In addition to regulating the battery charge
and energy load, it's also a timer for the
light's operation.
Next up is the solar array.
It's a group of photovoltaic panels or solar
cells.
The technician sets the solar array front,
side down on the workbench.
He threads cable through an aluminum back
panel.
This cable will serve as a ground wire.
He pushes a pop rivet through a hole beside
the cable and slides the eyelid on the end of
the cable over it.
He then pulls the pin through the rivet.
He threads wires from the panel junction box
into the opening beside the ground cable.
He tucks them into a flexible cable at the
back.
He rivets the aluminum backplate to the
solar panel array.
He pulls the wires from the junction box
through holes in a cover.
He sadr's electrical pins to the ends of the
wires and plugs them into a single connector.
With a junction box cover installed.
The solar street light system is ready for
final testing.
The team assembles the streetlight to a pole
in the factory.
They connect everything and stuff the wires
into the poles cavity.
They screw the LED light fixture to the
bracket on the pole and it's ready to shine.
The street lamp controller senses when it's
dark and automatically illuminates.
It will also detect a well-lit environment
and switch the light off.
Now that street smarts.